an emotional Robert teles appeared  before a judge this morning the former  Clark County public administrator was in  court for a bail hearing he's accused of  stabbing local investigative reporter  Jeff gearman to death in early September  telus's public defender argued he does  not pose a threat to the community but  the state argued that since Telus is  facing life in prison he is a Flight  Risk  in this case the safety of the community  argument  Mr Telus is a danger to No One the  evidence in this case is overwhelming  proof is evident presumption is great  according to the Constitution and our  statutes he is not entitled to bail at  this point the DNA  the judge ruled Telus will remain  detained without bail at